last night at president biden's
direction u.s military forces conducted
precision airstrikes in derazor syria
which is in eastern syria
our forces accomplished their mission of
destroying several infrastructure
facilities used by militia groups
affiliated with iran's islamic
revolutionary guard corps or irgc
the strike was necessary to protect and
defend u.s personnel in syria which have
been the targets of several recent
attacks by iran backed militia groups
including the most recent ones on august
15th
our response was proportionate and
precise it was designed to minimize the
risk of casualties and it responded to
to the nature of the attacks
by iran-backed militia groups that being
said we cannot accept further attacks on
our personnel this operation is a
demonstration that the united states
will not hesitate to defend itself
against iranian and iran-backed
aggression when it occurs
now let me turn to the focus of today's
briefing um let me join president biden
and secretary austin in underscoring our
continued support for the people of
ukraine as we mark their 34 31st year of
independence
uh we are now six months into russia's
brutal premeditated invasion of ukraine
an act of aggression meant to undermine
that independence
russia's efforts have not succeeded and
will not succeed and as we have made
clear at every level of this
administration we are committed to
sustained security assistance as ukraine
defends its sovereignty and territorial
integrity we are with ukraine today and
alongside our allies and partners we
will stick with ukraine over the long
haul
in light of this enduring commitment the
department of defense has decided to
provide an additional
2.98 billion dollars in security
assistance to ukraine under the ukraine
security assistance initiative or usai
as you all are aware this is the largest
single security assistance package we
have ever provided to support ukraine
in previous briefings we've discussed
various presidential drawdown authority
packages or pda packages it's important
to note that usai is different from
presidential drawdown because we will be
procuring these systems under usai from
the private sector rather rather than
pulling them out of our own stocks which
is what we do with pda
by its very nature this usai package
underscores our commitment to supporting
ukraine for the long term representing a
multi-year investment in critical
defense capabilities
this package is about building enduring
strength for ukraine as it continues to
defend its sovereignty in the face of
russian aggression
vladimir putin seems to believe that
russia can win the long game outlasting
the ukrainians and their will to fight
and the international community's will
to continue to support ukraine
this usai package is a tangible
demonstration that this is yet another
russian miscalculation the cap the
capabilities in this package are
tailored to sustain ukraine's most
critical capability needs in the medium
to long term and they include
six additional national advanced
surface-to-air missile systems or nasams
with additional munitions for those
nasams
up to
245 000 rounds of 155 millimeter
artillery ammunition which is the
ammunition used for the nato standard uh
artillery systems that have been
transferred to ukraine
up to 65 000 rounds of 120 millimeter
mortar ammunition
up to 24 counter artillery radars
we're also
including in this package puma unmanned
aerial systems or uas and support
equipment for scan eagle uas systems
we're including vampire counter unmanned
aerial systems
laser-guided rocket systems and a
substantial funding package for training
maintenance and sustainment so that
ukraine can keep the equipment they
already have in the fight
deliveries of this usai package will
begin in the next several months and
continue over the coming years while
many of these capabilities are not
intended direct to directly contribute
to today's fight they will form the
backbone of a robust future ukrainian
force capable of defending ukraine for
years to come
stepping back for a moment the united
states has now committed more than 13.5
billion dollars in security assistance
to ukraine since the beginning of the
bide administration including 12.9
billion dollars in the last six months
this level of u.s security assistance is
historically unprecedented and
demonstrates our unwavering support for
a free and democratic ukraine on its
independence day
this may be our largest security
assistance package to date but let me be
clear it will not be our last we will
continue to closely consult with ukraine
on its near mid and long-term capability
needs
we are far from alone in this effort as
i noted in my last briefing earlier this
month at least 50 countries have now
provided billions of dollars worth of
additional security assistance to
ukraine since russia invaded and
participated uh invaded in in february
and these allies and partners have
participated in the monthly ukraine
defense contact group meetings that have
been hosted by secretary austin
our continued unified efforts will help
ukraine continue to be successful today
and build enduring strength to ensure
the ukrainian people are able to
commemorate many more independence days
for years to come and with that i think
we're going to take the first question
from the ap thank you sir lita
thank you um
so one sort of specific question and
then uh a broader question um the
vampires can you give us a a sense of
how far down the road that is what kind
of what a little more detail what they
are and how far down the road that is
because i think it's a fairly new system
and then more broadly can you tell us
how much of the package is on
tr would fund training
and is the u.s going to expand training
give us a
picture of u.s training for
ukraine down the road into the future
yeah so the the vampire system itself is
a counter uas system it is a kinetic
system it uses small
missiles essentially to shoot uavs uh
out of the sky and we're happy to
provide you more technical details from
the right experts at the right time
um as it relates to training you know we
continue to train uh ukrainian forces on
all the systems that we are providing
and that our allies and partners are
providing um
that they haven't already been trained
on so as they've made kind of a
transition from
many cases soviet legacy equipment to
nato standard equipment that's required
more uh training and this has been
happening on a rolling basis now as it
relates to systems in this package since
really we're talking about systems that
will take months to get on contract and
you know one two three years in some
instances to arrive in ukraine
we think we're confident we we have the
time to train the ukrainians on whatever
systems uh you know they're not already
familiar with
do you know how much of the package is
on the sustainment training
well yeah the sustainment package sorry
the uh i answered as it relates to
training the piece of it that's about
sustainment i'll get you the exact
numbers uh on that afterwards but
sustainment is really about spare parts
uh the things that help them with uh
with maintenance is there a number for
the training though for training i don't
have a number of army i can give you
that
go
air force magazine thank you so much
can you tell us
why still no aircraft or pilot training
if you're thinking medium and long term
and also
why not include some systems like the
attackums the ata cms the army tactical
missile systems with ranges beyond 80
kilometers since russia is now moving
their logistics and command and control
beyond the range of the the current
munitions that we're sending thank you
yeah thanks uh so as it relates to
aircraft um our current priority uh as
it relates to aircraft is making sure
the ukrainians can use the aircraft they
currently have to generate effects uh in
the current conflict so uh for example
the last time we uh had a briefing here
uh we broke some news and talking about
the fact that we had provided them uh
some of these anti-radiation uh missiles
the harm missiles uh and um we had
adapted those missiles to be able to
fire off mig-29s they of course were not
designed to fly off russian equipment
they were
they were designed to fly off our uh
aircraft and the ukrainians in recent
weeks have been using the harm missiles
to great effect to take out russian uh
radar systems so you know as it relates
to future aircrafts fourth generation
aircraft for example uh even if we were
to provide those now they wouldn't they
wouldn't arrive for years so we've been
focused on as it relates to their
fighter aircraft and what they need for
the to support the current uh efforts to
hold in the east and perhaps go on on a
counter-offensive as it relates to the
future
of aircraft let me tell you where we are
in the process so secretary austin has
tasked uh uh the office of secretary of
defense to work with the joint staff and
european command essentially on a future
forces uh picture of kind of the
ukrainian force for the mid to long term
obviously this is done in close
consultation with the ukrainians it is
after all
uh their military
and we're really trying to be very
deliberate and disciplined about um what
type of ukrainian force matters in the
next 12 24 36 months under any range of
scenarios it could be a scenario in
which the war continues it could be a
scenario in which uh the violence uh
ebbs
because there's an agreement or because
uh it it just dies down a bit
but even in that instance the ukrainians
are going to need to defend their
territory and deter future aggression so
we're trying to be very deliberate about
what systems uh we think makes the most
sense for ukraine to have in that
context and also matters very much can
they sustain it can they afford it uh
because of course you know billions of
dollars of international assistance is
not is is you know may not be something
10 years from now or 20 years from now
so these also have to be
systems that ukraine itself can sustain
but i can tell you that uh fighter
aircraft remain on the table just no
final decisions uh have been made about
that
yeah as it relates to attack them so uh
i think as most of you are tracking um
you know we've been we've provided 16
hymar systems uh which are precision uh
rocket uh multiple launch rocket systems
a number of other allies have provided
similar systems the the brits and the
germans in particular have provided m270
systems the highmars is a truck it
launches the rockets off the back the
m270s launches the same rockets but
essentially off the chassis of a bradley
fighting vehicle type of armored vehicle
we have provided them uh guided multiple
launch rocket systems or gimblers that
have a range
of you know around 70 or 80 kilometers
we have provided them with hundreds and
hundreds of these precision guided
systems and the ukrainians have been
using them to extraordinary effect on
the battlefield it's our assessment that
the most relevant munitions for the
current fight are the gimblers and so we
have prioritized getting the ukrainians
the gimblers they need not only to uh
hold in the east but generate some
momentum uh elsewhere in the country
it's our assessment that they don't
currently require attackums to service
targets that are directly relevant uh to
the current fight um you know we'll
obviously continue to have conversations
with the ukrainians about about their
needs but it's our judgment at the
moment uh that we should be focusing on
gilmore's not attack thank you that's
okay sorry abraham we're gonna move on
we'll go to afp and then we'll go out to
the phone line sylvie thank you
speaking about gamblers
you
there is you mentioned
laser guided rocket system i suppose
it's it's them
can you
say
um
how many and how long they are supposed
to
to last
how how long does it's going to take for
them to receive them and
for how long
yeah i mean so it's going to take um
so you're asking about the rocket
systems in particular correct let me
make sure i have all the information for
you so the laser the laser-guided rocket
systems provided in this tranche of
funding
um will basically complement the systems
that ukrainians already have been
provided in previous security assistance
packages
the the uh the specific rocket systems
have a range of about eight kilometers
and they can be used basically to target
russian capabilities like armor
personnel carriers and unmanned aerial
systems in terms of the delivery
timeline uh some of those systems and
rounds will probably be provided to the
ukrainians within the next nine months
and additional systems and rounds could
take a year or two
this package does doesn't uh
there are no gimblers there there are no
gimbals in this package no the way that
well because the because we've been
focusing on uh providing gimblers
through the pda packages so the most
recent so we've been in we in every just
about every pda package uh we have
provided a steady stream of of gimler's
hundreds and hundreds uh at a time um
it's our assessment that the ukrainian
stocks of gimbals are pretty good right
now and we're going to continue to
provide those but but remember the
distinction i drew before that you know
pda is essentially something we can draw
it out of our own stocks to make it not
immediately available but usually in the
matter of days or weeks whereas usi is
typically months or years okay let's go
to the phone lines do we have tom
squitery from red snow news
thanks good afternoon uh doctor could
you just give give us a little more
clarity please on the timeline there has
been some delays in the past of
contracting uh equipment for delivery to
ukraine
could you just be being more specific on
the timeline please thank you is there a
timeline for a particular system you're
interested in because the timelines are
all different for the various timelines
well let me rephrase let me rephrase the
question then have has the pentagon
experienced any difficulties in
contracting in the past for these kind
of weapons and if so how's that been
factored into the timeline
well i mean the short answer is we're
eager to get the ukrainians the systems
as quickly as the process will allow um
we it takes sometimes months to get
these uh systems on uh contract um
that's been the case with the naysams
for for example
so in each case we will endeavor to get
the contracts uh uh filled out as
quickly as possible and get stuff on the
road but i think we have to manage
people's expectations these packages
the package of capabilities here are
really aimed at getting ukraine uh what
they're going to need in the medium to
long term so it's not relevant to the
fight today tomorrow next week it is
relevant to the ability of ukraine to
defend itself and deter further
aggression a year from now two years
from now and this is this is actually
extraordinarily important uh because as
least as we can discern
uh uh vladimir putin has not given up on
his overall strategic objectives of
seizing most of ukraine toppling the
regime
reclaiming ukraine as part of a new
russian empire what he has done is
lengthened his timeline in recognition
that uh he's off plan
and so as a consequence
his theory of victory is that he can
wait everybody out he can wait the
ukrainians out because they'll be
exhausted and attributed he can waste us
out because we'll turn our attention uh
uh elsewhere he can wait the europeans
out because of high energy prices or
whatever uh and so packages like this
are extraordinarily important in
directly challenging putin's theory of
the case which is that we're not in it
for the long haul that we aren't
supporting ukraine for the long haul so
um the other uh value in u.s using the
usai money is that you know they're
when we take things about out of our own
stocks we're taking things out of our
own stocks and that puts certain
constraints on what we can provide on
what timelines when we do usai we are
buying stuff uh on contract and
therefore the private sector can produce
uh can produce these things
but it takes a longer time we'll go to
tara and then to
nancy
does the building's assessment now that
this war is winnable for ukraine um and
that's why there's this announcement of
this multi-year the u.s will continue to
provide these arms in the long term and
then can you provide some context is
this not only the biggest tranche to
date for ukraine but is this the biggest
security assistance package provided in
any conflict
individually
for afghanistan iraq i realize that
might take some time to uh to put in
context
yeah the latter question i think
my sense is it is historically unusual
uh whether it's historically
unprecedented and it's in its sheer size
i think we're going to have to get back
back to you on it it's also it may not
be an apples-to-apples comparison uh in
terms of the types of things usai is not
equivalent to you know foreign military
uh funding for example um so anyway
let's get back to you on the whether
it's the biggest of all time um i think
the sheered amount of security
assistance we've provided through a
combination of pda and uh usai is
historically unprecedented as far as we
can tell because we're now north of 13
billion dollars uh with this and you
know uh 12.9 billion dollars just since
the uh the invasion kicked off on on
february 24th
in terms of the rel in terms of
essentially does the package represent
some assessment about the end game
i think the shortest answer to that is
no uh it's actually agnostic to what the
word what the you know the end game is
obviously it's important for us uh that
uh that ukraine uh survives and endures
as a democratic uh independent uh uh
sovereign country uh with its
territorial integrity uh intact it's
important to us that uh that russia pays
a cost in excess of the benefits they
gain from aggression so that they don't
do it again uh and so that other
aggressors uh uh take that lesson it's
also important to us that that uh
vladimir putin's objective of weakening
the west and fragmenting nato actually
has turned on its head uh that nato
emerges stronger the free world emerges
stronger i think we're on track to
achieve all three of those objectives
are you independent sovereign democratic
ukraine that endures russia
that has paid more costs than benefits
and west that is stronger than uh when
this started
this type of
package does not presume uh any
particular outcome of the conflict in
ukraine so for example
uh if the war continues uh for years
this package is relevant uh if there is
a ceasefire or a peace settlement this
package is still relevant uh because
ukraine needs the ability to defend
itself and deter uh future aggression so
kind of under any uh uh scenario or all
the ones in between we think uh that the
package is relevant okay we'll go to
nancy and then we'll go to the phone
lines
you talked about the strikes in syria
there have been reports of additional
u.s strikes in syria can you give us any
additional information about that
also um you receive questions are there
three
you also had questions about training
how much of this was dedicated training
you said you couldn't give us a number
can you give us a sense of how many
people would be trained and over what
time period
and finally you talked about this as a
an investment in ukraine's military in
the medium to long term i think you
talked about three years
is it your assessment that at three
years that ukraine will be fully uh
integrated into the nato into nato uh
weapons systems you anticipate they will
no longer need soviet um weapons systems
at that point can you can you give us a
picture what you envision the ukrainian
military looking at
looking like at the end of this weapons
package thank you yeah so just on this
on the syria strikes we're tracking the
same reports uh you are that there's
been an exchange uh uh
in syria i don't have any details to
provide you when when we have more we'll
we'll give you more i will say as a
general matter
we're not going to hesitate to defend
ourselves and uh we've communicated this
both in the actions that were took uh
last night the nature of those actions
um and also what we have communicated uh
uh to the iranians we're not going to
tolerate attacks by iran-backed forces
on our forces
anywhere in the world to include in
syria
and we won't hesitate to protect
ourselves and take additional measures
as appropriate now in this particular
case
our response was i think
extraordinarily carefully calibrated it
was meant to be proportional to the
attacks that the iran-backed groups
carried out on august 15th it was very
precise
we had essentially scoped out 11 bunker
targets on this site we ended up
prosecuting nine of them because
shortly before the strike
there was new evidence that there might
be individuals near two of the other
bunkers so we held off striking those
out of an abundance of caution because
our goal was not to produce casualties
in this instance
but we will continue to respond if our
people are uh are are attacked uh and
but as it relates to the additional
reports we'll we'll tell you more when
we know more
um
as it relates to the training numbers i
don't have the specific numbers uh in
front of me nancy we'll we'll get back
to you with with whatever details you
need for uh for your your story uh on
that
at three years will we be done you know
will the ukrainians be done
transitioning nato standard equipment
you know my sense is they will large
they will still have some aspects you
know for example they have hundreds and
hundreds of 152 millimeter uh
artillery systems they also have
considerable industrial capacity it is
conceivable that years from now they
could still be using those systems
produced by uh you know using munitions
that they themselves produce i will say
though i would anticipate that um in the
time frame we're talking about here that
ukraine will gradually transition to
nato standard equipment you're already
seeing that um in the transition to the
m777 howitzers and other similar systems
like the french cesar system that use
the 155 millimeter systems there's you
know high mars uh is another example
some of the uas uh systems i think one
of the things that will be you know
important as as we think through this uh
alongside ukraine in the coming years is
how can we and secretary austin is very
uh seized with this is
what does the future force of ukraine
look like that's sustainable uh and the
reality is that in the six months of
this war
um it's been an all hands on deck
situation right uh security assistance
flowing in from more than 50 countries
but that also means dozens of systems
and ideally the ukrainian military of
the future will not be rooted in dozens
of different systems but a much smaller
number of systems
that are uh you know easier to sustain
and maintain and all that so you know
let's see where the future holds but
just know that we're very focused here
in helping ukraine try to plan out uh
what is kind of a rational force of the
future and i would anticipate a lot of
that will include nato standard
equipment okay let's go out to the phone
line uh do we have oscar korczynski from
the polish press agency
hi thank you thank you
um
a couple of questions
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
will you
yeah so oscar we were having a little
trouble hearing you hear there was some
echo so um hopefully i'll answer the
question so the the question of an
attack is essentially you know it's a
version of the question before why have
we decided not to provide the uh attack
as of yet
i will tell you our primary
consideration is uh our judgment about
what is most uh useful and efficient for
what the ukrainians need for their uh
current purposes which are to hold in
the east and to generate momentum
elsewhere uh in the country and why do
we say that we consulted very closely
with the ukrainians about the types of
of targets that they needed to be able
to prosecute inside ukrainian uh
territory the vast majority of those
targets uh were rangeable
by uh jaimars using gimler's as opposed
to the much longer range
attackums
and so we have been emphasizing
providing them gimblers and by the way i
should i should note it's had an
extraordinary effect uh the i think as
all of your reporting and other
reporting has suggested um you know this
isn't just an average rocket this is the
equivalent of kind of a 200 pound
precision guided air strike launched off
the back of a truck uh and the
ukrainians have been using this to for
precision strikes against command and
control facilities logistical uh nodes
and other sustainment uh facilities and
it has had the effect we believe of
frustrating uh uh russia's advances in
the east um i think it's really they've
the russians have really slowed down uh
and the in the east and it's held uh
russian assets at risk elsewhere in the
country that's very much complicated uh
russia's planning efforts so it's our
assessment that um the gamblers are the
most important thing to continue
emphasizing and there's a steady flow of
those going uh going to ukraine as it
relates to your question about you know
obviously part of this packages look is
to signal a long-term commitment to
ukraine what about the long-term
commitment to the broader uh region i
would assume to include poland uh uh and
other countries on the eastern flank um
i think as you all saw from the most
recent madrid setting um our posture is
more robust than it was before this
crisis and
you know before the crisis we had
between 70 and 80 000 forces in the
yukon aor we now have around a hundred
thousand uh forces in the in the in the
aor we had on any given day around three
uh you know two brigade uh combat teams
or three brigade combat teams now we're
at five we will be at a steady state of
four
one of those will be headquartered in
poland uh as it currently is another one
will be headquartered in romania but
they'll be available uh to do exercises
and reinforce all up and down uh the
eastern flank so whether that be uh you
know poland and the baltic states or
whether it be uh in places like romania
bulgaria hungary uh slovakia uh etc
we've also put a couple of additional
ddgs are going to be flowing into spain
uh those are naval assets we're going to
be putting uh f-35s into the into the uk
uh and there are other movements as well
and i think one of the things that we've
demonstrated through this crisis is that
a lot of the investments we made
in um in improving our forward posture
and our infrastructure after the 2014
uh
illegal annexation of crimea and the
beginning of the violence uh in the
donbass a lot of that work uh has paid
off because of what it allowed us to do
early in the crisis is to nimbly move
around yukon forces forces that may have
been further back were able to flow
forward very quickly because the
infrastructure was there the
pre-positioned equipment was there and
so i would say that it's important as
even as we look at the eastern flank to
not only look at the capabilities that
are resident every single day in those
countries but the ability of the united
states and nato to surge forces forward
and one of the things that we came out
of the madrid summit with was a
commitment not just by the united states
but other countries like germany the uk
canada etc to put in place uh
commitments and infrastructure to be
able to rapidly surge forward into the
eastern flank so i think that is
signaling a long-term commitment not
just from the united states but from the
rest of nato to security in the east
okay we have time for just a couple more
let's go to fadi and then go back to
carla thank you thank you for doing this
good question
on ukraine on iran you just mentioned
that the u.s communicated to the
iranians that
we will not tolerate any attacks on u.s
troops was that made directly through
direct channels to iran and then on
ukraine the first thing on the
funding for training is this since we're
talking about long term here is it only
training on equipment or does it involve
other things like tactical
fighting and then you said
since this is a long-term commitment
you're not presuming any outcome
however most
often time wars end with political
settlements
and huge
say huge security
systems like this impact at the end of
the day political calculus so
why don't you factor in the possibility
of being able to have an impact on
russians willing to be engaged in
political dialogue to end this war yeah
so on that actually i think we're in
exactly the same place as your question
suggested israel i made clear a bunch of
times that a big part of the reason for
this commitment is actually to challenge
putin's theory of victory right his
theory of victories that he cannot
outlast everybody
packages like this that signal we're not
just providing assistance to ukraine
right now but it's going to be a steady
stream of assistance that will stretch
out over many months and years is
precisely challenging putin's
miscalculation we believe that he can
just grind it out and wait it out
so it is uh uh supposed to impact uh his
calculus um we're also largely through
our pda packages trying to affect the
calculus in the nearer term obviously by
enabling the ukrainians to defend the
territory they have push back where they
can so that when and if negotiations
start whenever that happens they have
the best hand
at the negotiating table so we're very
mindful of that as well the point i was
making is that the usai package matters
essentially no matter what world we end
up in
so clearly we hope that the usai package
helps to send a particular signal to
putin that he can't just wait everybody
out and that
hopefully incentivizes
russia to stop the fighting
and to
and to
get down to negotiations but if it
doesn't and the fighting contin and the
fighting continues then the assistance
uh continues to be relevant if it does
incentivize him just to uh strike a deal
the assistance is still relevant because
ukraine will have to hedge against the
possibility that russia could do uh this
again
on uh on iran um i'm not gonna go much
further than i already said we we have
passed messages i'm not gonna go through
uh exactly what channels we have lots of
ways of communicating to them and we
have uh tapped all of those channels to
make it clear to the iranians that what
they're doing is unacceptable
and that we will defend ourselves where
necessary i should say by the way um
you know
the other piece of iran
business
right now is the conversation about the
jcpoa the nuclear deal and i should just
make clear that what the strikes last
night illustrated is that
you know our commitment uh to push back
against iran's support for terrorism
militancy and the threats that they
engage in against our people in the
region or elsewhere are not linked to
wherever we end up on the nuclear deal
so
there's the nuclear nuclear diplomacy
lane
you know the president has been pretty
clear the administration has been pretty
clear that in the event that iran moves
back into compliance uh with the jcpoa
that's in our interest because it pushes
iran further away from a nuclear weapons
capability but whether
the jcpoa is is is reborn or not uh it
actually has nothing to do with our
willingness and resolve uh to defend
ourselves and i think the strike last
night was a pretty clear communication
to the iranians that these things are
are are on different tracks lastly just
on training on equipment and tactics i
will say that um you know for the most
part we've been prioritizing training
ukrainian troops on the systems that
they need to be able to very rapidly uh
employ in the field obviously with these
systems we'll have a longer time period
those interactions do have
the ability
to you know pass on not just the
technical details but also tactics
techniques and procedures
you know how to use these in combination
with other capabilities so we'll do our
best uh to make sure that we're we're
kind of synergizing the the training in
that way okay we'll go to the final
question voa
thank you for doing this i have one on
ukraine and then i'd like to ask one on
taiwan if i may um so on ukraine the
pentagon suggested that 10 switchblade
600s were going to be going into ukraine
have any of those arrived in theater and
will this package include
any switch value 600
yeah so this package doesn't it includes
uh uh
puma uas systems and then also some
additional parts for uh for scan eagle
um uh but it does not include uh
switchblade 600s and as it relates to
the actual delivery of the switchblades
i'll have to get back to you i don't
have that information in front of me you
had a question on taiwan yes
we've seen this just this week that the
pla is still maintaining an aggressive
tempo
flying close to taiwan
has the pentagon seen any indications
that this is going to slow down and
should we view this as the new normal
over in taiwan at the taiwan straight
yeah so our assessment i mean i think
we're still we'll still
have to see what settles out and what
the new normal looks like i'll tell you
what we've seen thus far
the tempo of their activities is less
than it was in the immediate aftermath
of speaker pelosi's visit but it's still
higher than historical norms
and they have clearly used this
particular incident uh to try to uh
essentially de facto erase uh the norm
of the center line for example of
crossing between this you know the
median position between mainland china
and the island of taiwan they have been
more active in the air they have been
more active at sea
um uh so i think we should anticipate
that whatever the ultimate level ends up
being it will be higher than it was
before and that speaks to your question
about uh the new normal um and we'll
continue to adjust our activities uh to
make sure that
wherever uh china uh ends up settling
that we may clear a couple of things uh
we remain committed to to uh defending
our allies and partners in the region we
remain committed to a stable free and
open indo-pacific which is i think an
interest that
all our allies and partners in the
region
subscribe to
and that we will continue to operate
in the air at sea wherever international
law
allows and that will include
freedom of navigation operations taiwan
straight
transits
and other activities so look our view of
this is that um
you know china took the speaker's visit
as an excuse to manufacture a crisis and
to set a new normal
and that
what we need to do is is to show that we
and the rest of the international
community will not be coerced uh that
what what beijing wants is for the
international community to react to
their new normal by taking a step back
and saying whoa uh uh you know we don't
want any piece of that and our reaction
is not to invite uh conflict or uh to
generate unnecessary frictions but to
basically uh make clear that beijing's
gambit isn't going to pay off that if
their goal was to coerce us and the
international community uh to back off
it's not gonna work
you know there have been a number of
attacks by these iranian-backed groups
against u.s forces and facilities in
iraq and syria uh in the last year or so
including a a pretty egregious one
against atg last october and there
hasn't been a u.s kinetic response like
last night can you just explain why the
u.s decided to respond to these on
august 15th when they're
they don't seem to have been so far out
of the norm from the other ones we've
seen yeah i'm gonna be a little careful
here uh
due to classification issues but i'll
say this a part of part of it's an
accumulation um that we want uh we don't
want iran to draw the wrong conclusion
that they can continue just doing this
and and get away with it but part of it
was also the nature of the attacks on
the 15th the fact that they were
coordinated against two u.s facilities
at the same time the fact that we
believe we have iran dead to rights
on
on attribution uh the the uav parts that
we've collected for example traced
directly back uh to tehran
so i think
our concern was that um this might be an
indication that iran intends to do more
of this and we wanted to disabuse them
of any sense that that was a good idea
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
appreciate it
you